hi
thanks um and uh i guess
as it's obvious now i'm here to talk
about building web services with go
uh something that i've done quite a bit
of in
my work at bettable so far so my name is
richard crowley as they said here's how
you get a hold of me on the internet
and uh this company embeddable we're a
gambling operator it's
gambling as a service and i've got dibs
on the blackjack guy
we're we're a licensed regulated entity
and we build a platform so that other
game developers don't have to worry
about the math or the money
or the legal parts and get to just do
what they do best which is of course
build games
and we build a lot of web services we
have at this point i think
more services in production than we have
engineers working on them
so we went to the kind of extreme side
of service oriented
and
actually work do i look completely
awesome
so let's try to put a definition
service it's a set of data and a set of
operations that you can do to that
what makes it a web service is that it's
accessed over the network over http
it's not something local or or you know
in memory
and what makes it a web service and not
a web application
is that it's uh it's based on structured
data that machines can parse and make
make decisions about something that is
part of a larger system rather than what
the end user sees necessarily
and so this is um the most basic silly
web thing and go and i would argue it's
not quite a web service yet but we're
going to get there
so hello dub dub dub is just a function
that uh that's registered with the the
http library and then we we serve it on
port 8080 and we call it a day
and there's a curious thing about all
this you know underneath the
the fact that it's a closure and that
we're calling handle funk whatever that
is and with that we give it slash as a
route
there's this this method signature
that's noteworthy you know
it looks kind of go like it has a
response writer which you know the
response being the output it's it's sort
of that
outputs before inputs pattern in in the
arguments
and it's this uh response writer thing
which incidentally is an interface and
some folks don't realize
and then a request and this is this is
our baseline for handling an http
request
and it just so happens that this
interface is
is the is the http handler interface
it's the it's the baseline from the
standard library and
when you put it in the form of an
interface they call it serve http
and this is going to come up over and
over and over again and i know
that we're we're programmers so our
first instinct when we see
a really simple interface like this is
just build more stuff on top of it
and that's great because that stuff has
to be built
but i would encourage you and and i'm
going to try to convince you through the
rest of this talk
that this lowest common denominator here
this handler interface
is what all go web services should be
built from it's
what allows posibility and
interoperability and
and separation of concerns that makes go
great so i encourage you to embrace this
interface and don't
don't soil it up too much so let's
rewrite
the the hello dub dub dub service that
we had a minute ago
in terms of this new handler so we're
gonna now we're gonna have a
type called handler and we're gonna
implement the serve http method
and it's the same as before we just
funk.printline fprintline
to the responsewriter which of course is
a writer and that's how all that works
and i went ahead and added setting a
content type header and being explicit
about the
the response status just so we can see
how all of that fits together
and at this point we still we don't
really have a web service
so let's turn it into one and of course
we do that we we json because that's all
we mean by web services these days
anyway right
so the change is pretty minimal we've
changed the content type to be
application json
because we're good citizens in the http
land and
we've traded out just writing to our
writer to uh to creating to wrapping it
with
a json encoder and then we encode an
object that i just made up
into json and that's what actually
written out to the browser
or or the client or or whatever the
unfortunate thing here is that because
we're encoding json because maybe we
have utf-8 problems there's a
possibility that we have an error still
and so we've
we've kind of muddled the problem of
just
writing an object out to uh to our
client and
that's kind of unfortunate now
it's interesting also to note that an
error response
in in terms of http and go is
relatively indistinguishable from a
successful response this is
almost exactly the same code as we saw a
moment ago when we replied 200 okay
but this time it's a 500 and of course
that's the worst possible thing that can
happen in the world
the tr the real problem is that there's
no
error value so this doesn't feel like an
error condition
from the the go source code sense and
that's
a little bit unfortunate because it's
kind of an impedance mismatch between
the the language that we're speaking
with our clients and the language that
we're using internally in our software
so we're going to come back to later how
to bridge the gap and make
go errors into http error so that
everybody kind of gets on the same page
what after here is is this where we have
functions that return errors or maybe
they return
something else and an error and we use
that error
not to explode like an exception because
the errors are not
usually exceptional they're merely
our opportunity as a as the programmer
of the thing being called to express
what happened to the caller perhaps what
happened is
is that what you expected to happen
happened and so you return a nil error
to say everything's fine
but it's still an opportunity to tell
the caller what happened
perhaps how to recover perhaps a little
more detail about
their bad inputs or the the terrible
state of the world that caused it to be
that way
so you know don't just uh don't just
return an error string that says
fail that's that's not super helpful
even though that's exactly what i did
here
so back to the http stuff we've got this
handler interface with its server http
method
and it seems like that's sort of the end
of the road that
it's such a simple thing that we can't
express all the things that we'd like to
do with the web service
which usually actually becomes a lot of
different things a lot of different
operations
data and the answer to that is actually
pretty simple the handlers
are a tree so to speak that handlers
handle other handlers and it's
passing on and on and on down and uh so
some of them end up multiplexing to
various handlers depending on url
prefixes or header values or or what
have you
some handlers serve static content some
handlers gzip the
the request or unpack the the
sorry gzip the response or unpack the
request from some bizarre format
and we can build a lot of interesting
things with these handlers
and so uh of doing this is
i've expanded once again our base
http example here and i've added in the
the servox from the standard library
which the first couple of lines there
are bringing back the very original
example where our handler that we define
the serve http method on is being
registered at the slash url
so that that path is is what gets routed
to our handler and of course we could
add
lots of different paths there and have
handlers that react to
any number of uh of things in the the
request the the headers the
the time of day whatever you like and
then we've expanded a little bit further
at the bottom
to uh to separate out what was before it
was just listen and serve and now
we've got uh listener and then we
serve from that listener the uh
and so this is actually starting to beg
the question
how reliable is this stuff anyway how
can we can we trust the http
server that's that's in the standard
library um raise your hand if you've
been burned by
ruby by python by anything else that has
a crap web server and standard library
yep so we need to we need to see if
it's up to the challenge um and of
course if
if you came to the meetup a couple
months ago you saw brad talking about
how it in
it definitely is and uh here's briefly
how
so think about an echo server that's you
know you're dealing with the the network
directly
where you listen and then what do you do
logically
you get into a loop where you accept
connections and then handle a bunch of
connections in parallel and in go how we
do that is we accept connections in our
accept loop
and then we go handle that connection
and that spins it off
out into the background and the great
thing is that we can have thousands of
them
so in our handle function that's off on
its own we just
in our echo server read write read write
read write all day long we don't have to
worry about
whether we've read enough and whether we
have a complete request and whether we
need to yield to the next guy because we
only have five threads because apache
it's simple it's it does what it says on
the 10 and that's fantastic
and the bonus is of course that it it
works at a large scale
so now that we've got a good web server
and we don't have to solve that problem
anymore
we uh people like me get back to uh the
next thing to do which is to make web
frameworks
and um and they're great right they keep
us from repeating ourselves
uh you know how how much code did rails
save you the first time you used it
right
they keep us from repeating ourselves
they keep us
they build powerful abstractions that
that make it
easier than just you know writing a web
service in c or something
but often a web framework requires you
to make to make a full buy-in to to give
your entire
world over to them and that's a little
bit problematic
so the the problem there is that often
that that full buy-in comes with a lot
of magic that you don't necessarily
understand
or even want to understand and in go
often those sorts of frameworks
are incompatible with the basic http
handlers
that i'm telling you that you should
really be embracing
so that's that's the story that led
me and some co-workers to uh to develop
what we decided to call tiger tonic
um and it's it's a set of handlers more
than it is a web framework
um and it's inspired to a great degree
by drop wizard from java land
though ghost strengths allow it to look
very very different
incidentally the name is inspired by the
same webcomic that spawned drop wizard
so that sort of made sense to me
so i want to talk through a couple of
the things that it does and how they
work
so we can really drive home the point
that
that http handlers are all you need to
get anything done
so the standard library servmux that we
saw a little bit ago
is great but it only routes prefixes so
you
you can't do intricate routing without
managing a tree of handlers on your own
so the the tri serve mux i say it i say
it knew sway
sorry uh allows you to
get a little bit more surgical with your
handlers without managing that tree
yourself
and so we say that we want to get fubar
baths where
bar embraces there is a parameter that
gets expanded so it's it's
foo slash one two three slash baz and
we're gonna have a url parameter
to uh to get that one two three out and
because this is
handling the uh the full scope of the
urls under that
that mucks and the fact that it has
access to the method
means that it can respond 404 and it can
respond four or five
like a good web service should
and just like the servox the standard
library this
this thing that comes out of here is is
nothing but a handler itself so you can
kind of recurse on yourself and use that
over and over again
under the hood what it's actually
building up that same tree that you
would have to do
on your own but it's building it
internally and doing the parsing of your
urls
itself and uh the the leaves of that
tree are the various
that a particular url responds to and
like i said those wild cards
are pulled out into the the query
portion of the url so there's
they're available to you in your handler
without
any special syntax over top of the http
handler interface
next thing that we of course want to do
we we put a pin in it before is
is speak jason and it was a little bit
verbose last time
so so we want to take a little bit
better stab at it and
this is where we get to the the bit
about go being statically typed and how
awesome that actually is
because what we can do is define
functions with a slightly different
signature
so in this case it takes a url
a header and a request and that's a
that's a structure that i define and it
has whatever properties it wants
whatever json tags it wants
and the request is deserialized into
those
arguments and passed to a function that
i define
and then my obligation to that is to
respond with a status
a set of headers if i feel like it a
response object which again
the statically typed go object that can
be whatever i want
and an error which in this case is nil
so we're all going to be great
and by wrapping that in the marshalled
function we're turning that back
into a handler and the magic of of
dealing with jason of
of dealing with the the bad the bad
requests and the
uh the unacceptable requests and the uh
unsupported entity type or or whatever
that uh
whatever 4015 is um all of those are
handled by the framework and the output
is
is a handler that we can use wherever
so underneath here the the fact that
this is actually letting us declare
the request and response types ourselves
means that this is not
an interface in the classical go sense
which is
too bad because it means you have to get
out the reflect package
but that stays neatly tucked within
marshalled
and what it does is that it verifies
that the function is of
roughly the right shape at early run
time
and then it uh it constructs all the uh
the arguments for you so when a request
is coming in
we create with reflect.new
a new object of the type that you're
expecting
and let the json decoder decode into
that object and then you receive nothing
but the static type that you're
expecting
when we do it with a response it's a
little bit easier because the json
encoder is expecting an interface and
everything is an interface so it's all
happy still
we have a slightly different path for
errors
and that's uh that's how we're going to
get on top of this idea that
we should be able to work with go errors
and
let the framework deal with the fact
that the users are expecting to see a
500 response with some descriptive body
so when we need to write out an error we
do roughly the same thing where we set
the content type
we set the status code and we write a
json body
out to our response writer that says
that there's some error by some name and
and here's
what it's all about in some description
and
the the right json error and its
supporting functions
are allowing errors to implement extra
interfaces so if you implement status
code method
you can override what the http response
is going to be
if you override the name method then
you're going to have a different
name for your error so that you can pick
and choose whether you want to expose
the names of your types
or if you want a more generic you know
gtfo kind of error
it's all up to you and from these
primitives which are all still just
handlers we can
pose larger and larger handlers so a
great example
that comes up all the time is wanting to
conditionally handle a request
say you want to handle a request if
you're logged in
so we pass a function that reacts to the
request and either produces an
error or doesn't and if it doesn't then
our protected handler gets called
and this is purpose built
you know for for exactly what we're
trying to do
actual case of the more general that we
can
chain middleware together where we have
a bunch of handlers
and they all do whatever it is that they
want so perhaps we
try to enforce a rate limit and if
you're over the limit we respond
otherwise we let it fall through to the
next one where we see if you're logged
in and it's all
valid and if you're not we kick you out
but if you fall through once more we get
to the handler that does
actual work so we have a great amount of
code reuse here
and we're still left with this handler
whose behavior is to merely handlers
until it finds one that responds
and underneath it this is built up by
having a response writer remember i said
that that's an interface
it's a response writer that takes note
of whether you call
the right header method and as soon as
you do it bails out
so we can keep building bigger and
bigger chains of things and what we're
going to arrive at is a web service that
we want to put into production
and what tends to be the problem when
you get there or shortly after you get
there without realizing it
is that you have no idea what's going on
and people have
thousands of solutions to this problem
from
from reading apache logs to new relic to
everything in between
to trying to run your own graphite
system to
just like having a guy sitting at a
computer tailing
and all of that is great but
the framework can provide tools to make
that easier on you
so in the small in the really surgical
way where
you have one problematic request or
endpoint or something
that you need you need
very very verbose logs of what happened
and
we uh we at bettable have been using
this the first one here
tigertonic.logged
which will log the full request and
response bodies
headers everything for every request if
you think i'm crazy
try it you'll love it and there's a [ __ ]
redacting sensitive information because
of course bodies contain things like
credit card numbers and that would be
terrible to have in your logs it's a bad
day
for the more traditional among you you
can do apache logged in
and again what we're building is a is a
handler that wraps a handler
and reacts to whatever's happened
underneath i think now there is actually
a
json logged version that will work with
elasticsearch and logstash and stuff
like that
as well so that's in the small in
in the large when you're dealing with
millions billions of requests however
big you want to get you you know you
don't have time to look at all the logs
you need to be told where to look and so
you want to have counters of what your
popular endpoints are you want to have
timers to know what's too slow
you want to understand where the 99th
percentile is
way out of line you want to understand
where the the standard deviation of
response time is just
all over the place and you get that
not by not by sampling
uh from log data that has time stamps in
it you get that by having the
application
time interesting portions of the
application you can be
very selective about what you time or
what you count
and give yourself a lot more
intelligence than just blindly saying
how fast is this web server so
so that's for in production now before
you get there
you have to test your your services you
have to know that they're going to work
before you test whether whether they're
going to work quickly
and uh and so testing in go is i think
we can mostly agree pretty great i
actually have gotten to the point where
i
go write a test function to to try
something out sooner than i go to to the
play site sooner than i go
uh write a main function and i think
that's really really cool
and with web services you want to have
that same sort of instinct that the
easiest thing to do is to just
do a request the whole thing and see how
it works
so you can mock urls you can mock
headers
and uh and call your your functions that
you give to marshalled which give you
the sort of parts of
tested or you can re big and ambitious
and you can just call the serve http
the response recorder from the standard
library that would allow you to then
make assertions about the whole body
string or the headers or whatever
happened to come out of request
so that was uh a lot of uh pseudo self
promotion and
and talking about handlers and there's a
bunch of other stuff that's in
the library that we've found useful that
other people have found useful
that all combine to be just a set of
handlers that make
building web services faster and more
enjoyable
um and i i've been working over the past
couple days on my one more thing and i
got there this morning
i know it's come up in conversation at
this meetup before that graceful stop on
the web server would be
an amazing thing to have um and i have a
proposal that
is working within tiger tonic right now
that basically how it works
is group
to a net.listener rapper and a net.con
rapper
and that gives you the ability to close
a listener and
and then later know when all the
connections that were accepted by that
listener have been closed
but basically means that you're stuck
waiting
or for keepa lives to finally up and die
and the aha moment the other day was
that
if you control through a response writer
whether the connections send the
connection close header
on the response then you can short
circuit that and make it pretty quick so
now
you can do a graceful stop without
waiting on connections to die but merely
in-flight requests to finish
and so that is uh is my proposal for how
we make that work
at least without patching the standard
library which is probably still a better
solution
so in parting
use http handler and everybody here is
going to be happier because we can all
interoperably use your components to
make better web services
take that and then build your
abstractions up within that but
remember that mostly people are going to
be wiring them together from their most
basic components
and where possible you can use those
abstractions you build up to make
the the code feel a little bit more
go-like and and a little bit less like a
500 is kind of the same as the 200.
you can make your errors feel like go
errors even though they're not really
exceptional they're just
they're just part of life so uh there's
a couple of links
for anyone who cares i would
miss about saying uh especially
blackjack guy
that uh if the gambling industry is at
all interesting to you
if go is interesting to you uh hit us up
at bedable
thanks